okay let's go to your voicemails
voicemail number is two one nine two
david p you can call any time of day
many of you do call at very unusual
times of day and that's okay we heard
from the eggman recently and the eggman
is pointing out that he believes what
anthony weiner was found guilty of is
not nearly as bad as what alabama
republican senate candidate roy more is
accused of take a listen to what the
eggman said hi dave I think what Roy
Moore is accused of doing is so much
worse than what Anthony Weiner has been
convicted of doing I don't like all
these false equivalence as well what
about Clinton what about what about but
if they want to go that route what about
Weiner okay forget it
Roy Moore is fine he can do that but let
Weiner out and put him back in
governments guy I want to pull Weiner
off the farm team and bring him back out
because he's nothing compared to this
scumbag Roy Moore that's all yeah we're
against the ranking of sexual assault
and sex crimes but that being said I
think you can still draw similarities
and differences between different
incidents and I tend to agree with what
the eggman says I've never defended
Anthony Weiner's actions and I don't I
just don't think they're as bad as what
Roy Moore was accused of yeah I mean I
don't think the Anthony Weiner stuff
would be a big deal had he not sent
images of himself underage girl no doubt
about it
no no question about it so egg man thank
you very much for calling in and you can
see what he's thinking about these days
up there in upstate rural upstate New
York
he also said pull Weiner he's at the
yeah he wants to see Weiner pulled and
that's fine that's fine nobody'll on the
bonus show today why the massacre of
Muslims in the site in the Sinai was too
extreme even for al-qaeda what does that
even mean we'll also talk about a
mysterious object that has been
confirmed to be from another solar
system but it's not a UFO it's just an
object from another solar system we'll
talk about that on the bonus show and
are we heading towards YouTube ad
pocalypse 2.0 there is a new ad
pocalypse candle over videos
actual izing little kids on YouTube how
are we dealing with this again this
story and others on the bonus show today
get access by going to david pakman.com
slash membership and signing up or by
becoming a $5 a month patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
we'll speak to you then